our incredible shrinking president
that's the focus of tonight's angle
joe biden thought that he'd wipe away
the national disgrace of his afghan
withdrawal by addressing the nation with
an angry and hectoring tone today
we reached out 19 times to americans
in afghanistan
with multiple warnings the decision to
end the military lift operations at
kabul airport was based on the unanimous
recommendation
of my civilian and military advisors
their recommendation
was that the safest way to secure the
passage of the remaining americans and
others
out of the country
was not to continue with 6 000 troops on
the ground in harm's way in kabul
but rather to get them out through
non-military means
less than two weeks ago biden said would
stay until every american got out of the
country but today he claimed leaving 10
behind was a win
the bottom line
90
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave secretary
state blinken
is leading the continued diplomatic
efforts to ensure safe passage for any
american who wants to leave afghanistan
joe biden thought he would reverse the
public's growing distrust of his
presidency with bragging and meaningless
counterfactuals
imagine
if we'd begun evacuations in june or
july
bringing in thousands of american troops
and evacuating more than 120 000 people
in the middle of a civil war still would
have been a rush to the airport the
bottom line is
there is no evacuation evacuation
from the end of a war that you can run
without the kinds of complexities
challenges threats we faced none
and a slew of former top military
officials vehemently disagreed with him
in a letter yesterday and they echoed
what i've been saying on this show
defense secretary lloyd austin chairman
of the joint chiefs mark milley need to
go immediately
the nearly 90 retired generals wrote the
consequences of this disaster are
enormous and will reverberate for
decades our adversaries are emboldened
to move against america due to the
weakness displayed in afghanistan
of course the media well they gave this
little coverage today which is a tad
different from how they reacted any time
senior military or intel officials
hammered president trump
but back to our current shrinking
president biden
it's obvious from everything that's
happened over the past several weeks
that he doesn't care about the outcome
here
only what it means for his personal poll
numbers take for example today's report
about biden's july 23 phone call with
former afghan president ashraf ghani who
since fled the country with a bunch of
cash
now biden wasn't focused on the facts on
the ground as much as how it would look
if things ended up collapsing
in much of the call biden focused on
what he called the govern afghan
government's perception problem
i need not tell you the perception
around the world and in parts of
afghanistan i believe
is that things are not going well in
terms of the fight against the taliban
there's a need to project a different
picture
well once again he and his team are not
immersed in the details of the operation
but instead on the optics and the
possible political fallout
during trump's entire term in office
all we heard from the left was how
unpresidential and how disrespectful he
was and how he trampled on political
norms remember all that
but it was mr joe biden the most
experienced president ever who was
actually unpresidential and
disrespectful at the dover air force
base this past sunday
now think about this all he had to do
was stand there and show genuine respect
and empathy
but what he'll be remembered for is
looking at his watch and some
perfunctory comments to parents
it didn't go well
he talked a bit more about his own son
than we did my son and that that didn't
sit well with me in reference to
the
checking of his watch
that didn't happen just once
that happened on every single
one that came out of that airplane
i couldn't look at him anymore after
that
just considering especially the time and
why we were there it was
i found to be the most disrespectful
thing i've ever seen
but this is who joe biden is
he's always been a small-minded grifter
who's a generally been considered a
self-promoting buffoon for most of his
career that's why he wasn't nominated in
2016 after being vice president to
barack obama for eight years
think about it this way
over the past 50 years
biden never said anything significant or
meaningful never
and it was the same today his speech was
supposed to mark the end of our longest
war and yet
he literally sounded like any random
liberal pundit
like one of the joys
behar or reed
petty and trivial
even trump hating bill crystal panned it
at the end of a 20-year war you should
give a presidential speech you should
reflect on what it meant and instead it
was a very kind of legalistic defensive
defense of debating points in a way what
he had done over the last few weeks the
impression is he's not quite meeting
them at the moment i think
first of all i never thought i'd ever
agree with him again in my life nor did
i ever think i would ever play a sound
bite from bill crystal but there you
have it anything's possible
it's almost as if joe biden's
disappearing before our very eyes
he's just not all that relevant
the real political bait will continue
between the hard left and the rest of us
who want to save america from socialism
and decline
at least through the midterms domestic
policy is in the hands of schumer and
pelosi
important foreign policy decisions going
to be largely determined going forward
by the eu and china certainly not by
this little fellow
the fact is the rest of the world
doesn't take biden seriously
his own people don't even take him
seriously
even they either they don't let them
answer questions or they carefully
choose the reporters he'll take
questions from
ladies and gentlemen
he gave me a list here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc i'll take your
questions and as usual folks they gave
me a list
of the people i'm going to call on i'm
not i'm not supposed to take any
questions but go ahead
on afghanistan
[Applause]
brothers
[Music]
can you believe that
today he wouldn't answer any questions
he was just a warm-up act for jen saki
who occasionally does her best to spin
biden's incoherence but biden had that
mask on as he turned around make sure to
grab that great job joe
no one in the history of the world has
ever changed his or her mind on anything
as a result of a joe biden speech
and no one ever will
but after this latest disaster not a
single world leader is paying any
attention to joe biden anyway
he and america under his leadership is
diminished everything he touches goes
sideways
and then he ends up getting angry at you
when it does
he blames others as he did with donald
trump today while claiming at the same
time that the buck stops here
let me tell you what a real president
would have done today
he would have taken actual
responsibility for what unfolded and he
would have treated the families of the
fallen with real respect and real
compassion he wouldn't have talked about
his own family or his own loss
he would have fired everyone responsible
for the catastrophe
he would reassure the american people
that under his watch our troops would
never again be left as sitting ducks
and that our country would never again
be humiliated as we were in kabul
and a real president a real man
wouldn't have left 10 percent of
americans behind in
afghanistan he wouldn't have left one
behind
unfortunately for us for america
we won't have a real president for at
least another three years and five
months
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else